[Musica]
quante volte vi è capitato di sentir
dire che la filosofia non serve a niente
che è inutile che è aria fritta a me è
successo tantissime volte ma vi dirò di
più per un certo periodo di tempo ciò
anche creduto
il che è molto strano se consideriamo le
scelte che ho fatto
quando avevo 18 anni ed era il momento
di decidere a quale facoltà iscrivermi
intorno a me tutti sembravano molto
preoccupati
iniziarono a dirmi cose tipo beh scegli
una facoltà scientifica
almeno poi imparare un mestiere almeno
avrei un lavoro se proprio non vuoi fare
medicina pensa almeno non so a
ingegneria giurisprudenza economia
quantomeno poi avrei qualcosa da fare io
non capivo perché fossero tutti così
agitati ma forse loro avevano visto più
lontano di me prima che vede io ero
stata il tipo di bambina che inciampa e
cade in tutte le pozzanghere quella che
fa le domande imbarazzanti agli adulti e
quando mi chiedevano cosa avrei voluto
fare da grande rispondevo la poeta o la
fiorista fiorista poi ho dovuto scafat
farlo così come ho scartato varie
facoltà scientifiche perché
probabilmente avrei avuto dei grossi
problemi a calcolare i resti e clienti
senza contare che anche se ho sempre
avuto il pollice verde un conto è
occuparsi di qualche piantina un conto
avere un negozio che pullula di fiori
ecco però forse mi direte voi sto solo
cercando delle scuse in effetti può
darsi che sia vero e così un bel giorno
me ne uscì con la mia decisione presa ho
scelto di sì a tutti mi iscriverò a
filosofia e fu allora che cominciarono
le reazioni ma ti ha dato di volta il
cervello non avrei mai un lavoro poi
cosa fai
io ho deciso di iscrivermi a filosofia
un po perché pensavo di non saper fare
niente un po per curiosità un po perché
sono sempre stata disordinata e pensavo
che avrei trovato un metodo che avrei
trovato una disciplina è in effetti un
metodo l'ho trovato ma non nel modo che
mi aspettavo è oggi un lavoro ce l'ho ce
l'ho anche perché sono riuscite ad
aspettare abbastanza da far incontrare
le due cose che amo di più le cose che
ho studiato la filosofia e la cosa che
più mi piace fare scrivere ma arrivarci
non è stato facile c'è stato bisogno
prima che finissi mille pezzi che mi
perdessi perché le persone emotive come
me quando si perdono hanno la sensazione
di andare in mille pezzi sono andata in
mille pezzi prima di ritrovarmi quando
ho creduto agli altri quando ho creduto
che davvero non avrei avuto un lavoro se
non fossi stata la migliore di tutti e
allora mi sono messo a studiare come una
matta per essere la migliore per avete
per avere i voti più alti e non mi
bastava mai mi sforzavo i voti erano al
tiro brava ma non bastava mai
cercavo qualcosa ma non sapevo che cosa
mi sono buttata nella competizione ma la
competizione non fa per le persone
emotive
per questo ho iniziato a soffrire ho
iniziato a soffrire di ansia mi si
chiudeva la gola non respiravo bene non
dormivo bene ero molto agitata ho
passato molte ore
seduta su una sedia in biblioteca o
nella mia stanza china sulla scrivania a
studiare e pensavo di studiare per la
scuola invece me ne sono accorta solo
poi avevo studiato per la vita ci ho
guadagnato una scoliosi certo ma ci ha
guadagnato anche un nuovo modo di
guardare alle cose una nuova prospettiva
che era sorta in me proprio nel momento
in cui pensavo di essermi persa mi sono
persa e poi mi sono ritrovata quando ho
capito che non doveva imparare a memoria
le risposte ma dovevo trovare un nuovo
modo di fare le domande dovevo per
vincere l'ansia abbandonare mania di
voler controllare tutto dovevo lasciare
che il mondo mi attraversasse dovevo
essere aperta ed è quello che ho cercato
di fare grazie alla filosofia
c'è una frase che mi piace molto che mi
sembra che riassuma benissimo quello che
la storia del pensiero
la frase è questa siamo nani sulle
spalle dei giganti
cosa vuol dire beh innanzitutto il
riconoscimento di umiltà non c'è nessuno
che sia più umile di un nano umile vuol
dire vicino a terra poco elevato e un
nano accanto al gigante è la cosa più
umile che ci sia ma in questo
riconoscimento di umiltà del fatto che
noi siamo degli eredi forse indegni di
chi è venuto prima di noi di chi ha
pensato e ha scritto prima di noi c'è
anche dell'altro
c'è il fatto che non è molto maneggevole
per un gigante è un gigante se lo può
mettere sulle spalle e il nono allora
guarderà lontano il suo sguardo arriverà
molto più lontano di quanto non arrivi
quello del gigante stesso questo fa
della filosofia allarga la prospettiva
la prospettiva di un nano che dalle
spalle di un gigante vede ancora più
lontano c'è un'altra storia che mi piace
molto che mi viene sempre in mente
quando qualcuno mi dice che la filosofia
inutile è una storia che riguarda la
testa fra le nuvole che hanno i filosofi
e riguarda il primissimo di tutti i
filosofi talete un saggio
importantissimo uno di quei filosofi che
nella grecia antica iniziarono a porsi
domande su come funzionasse la natura
talete si faceva queste domande giorno e
notte letteralmente e una notte mentre
camminava con gli occhi fissi sulle
stelle alla luce della luna non guardo
dove mettere ai piedi
c'era un pozzo scavato per terra e lui
vince un po e ci cade dentro una
ragazzina che passava di lì lo vide
invece di aiutarlo rise and rise di lui
e quella risata sono riassunto e tutte
le critiche e tutte le prese di
posizione di chi dice che la filosofia
non serve a niente perché sa che può
essere filosofi a che preoccuparsi tanto
dei pensieri delle cose ultraterrene
quando non si guarda dove si mettono i
piedi
ma il punto di questa storia non è la
risata e non è neanche la caduta di
talete non è neanche il fatto che lui
sia inciampato e il fatto che mentre
inciampava lo scopriremo la cosa
importantissima l'ostinazione alla
ricerca che è qualcosa che ci può far
inciampare ci può far cadere a testa in
giù ma anche quello che ci fa vedere più
lontano degli altri è un patrimonio il
pensiero che può passare da una mente
all'altra da un gigante a un nano e che
amplia tutte le nostre prospettive
e a proposito di prospettiva cosa stava
vedendo talete a testa in giù dal fondo
del pozzo vedeva il cielo riflesso in
quel riflesso lui riuscì a indovinare
quello che tutti gli altri suoi
concittadini suoi contemporanei che
ridevano anche di lui non avevano
assolutamente visto
lo riuscì a capire nel momento in cui a
nessuno e veniva in mente di studiare il
cielo per cercare di indovinare cosa
avrebbe riservato il tempo dell'indomani
che poteva esistere una forma di scienza
quella che sarebbe diventata la
meteorologia e che permetteva di
prevedere cose come per esempio il
raccolto delle olive e così a furia di
interrogare le stelle e fenomeni
naturali si rese conto che un certo anno
il raccolto delle olive sarebbe stato
molto più abbondante e allora fece una
cosa affitto tutti frantoi della regione
così quando i suoi concittadini
dovrebbero fare l'olio tantissimo olio
per cui quell'anno c'erano tantissime
olive dovettero pagargli la concessione
unico esempio di filosofo che si sia
arricchito grazie alla filosofia ma
questa storia ci dice anche
qualcos'altro ci dice che la prospettiva
del filosofo che una prospettiva qualche
volta sotto sopra ne permette di vedere
la dove gli altri non vedono perché lo
sapete da dove nasce la filosofia
nasce dalla meraviglia dalla capacità di
lasciarsi stupire di lasciarsi
attraversare dal mondo da quello che ci
sconcerta da quello che ci fa dubitare
da quello che ci fa diventare come
bambini che infatti hanno un'inflazione
incredibile per la filosofia e allora
lasciamoci meravigliare lasciamoci
meravigliare lasciamo che la meraviglia
ci guidi a cercare nuove prospettive da
cui guardare le cose e se nel farlo
inciampare mo e finiremo a testa in giù
dentro un pozzo pazienza a chi ci dice
che la filosofia inutile potremo sempre
dire che serve come a imparare a vivere
[Applauso]
[Musica]